good morning everyone we're going to be
starting here in just a few more minutes
and we hope that we can send the correct
link
to everyone who registered to join
hello and welcome everyone uh we're
going to be starting in just a few more
minutes
and uh i think there was a mistake with
the link that was sent out so hopefully
everyone will join the correct meeting
this time
and uh today we're gonna be talking
about bioinformatics for infectious
diseases so
please give it just a few more minutes
as everyone is joining
and we'll be starting soon
all right hello and welcome to this
webinar on bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
and we're going to be starting here in
just a second so
i thank you for joining today and we're
going to be discussing the applications
of bioinformatics to the study of
infectious diseases
anyone who's joining us not on zoom
uh we do have uh an issue i think some
someone sent out the wrong link to join
this session on zoom
so if you are participating uh from
youtube
that's also great great to have you all
here
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases will be the topic of today's
session
uh but before we actually start the
session i wanted to talk a little bit
about
what we do in the omixlogic training in
general
and that will kind of give the context
for what we will be talking about today
so omixlogic is essentially a program
that combines the logic of data science
in application to biological data
with a community that is passionate
about developing
research projects using bioinformatics
tools
and applications of bioinformatics to a
variety of topics
and so we believe that the
the students clinicians faculty of all
backgrounds
need to be enabled with the skills and
the tools that are needed to process
large data sets so as we
go through the first several steps i
want to introduce you to some of these
resources that make this possible
and after we go through this first part
i
will be talking about the topics of the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
and as we will try a few things
with the hands-on exercises that we'll
do today so hopefully you can also
start by registering on the platform
that we will use
before we start this session okay if
you're having trouble
hearing uh please rejoin again um
and uh mohit and sonalika am i audible
can you hear everything fine oh yes are
you audible
all right thank you
okay so uh before we begin uh let me
just go through some of the
resources that we will be using today
the first one
is learn omixlogic.com now some of you
might already be registered on this
portal so if you already are registered
please make sure that you're logged in
and you have your password ready because
we're going to be doing a few examples
on our big data analysis platform to
kind of give you a sense of
what kind of exercises we'll be doing
so if you could please post the link
to the learn portal in the chat anyone
that wants to register so
learn.ormixlogic.com and
the way to register let me just go to
the site
is to go right here to the login and
then
you can either log in with your email
and password or create an account
or you can also use one of the social
media portals
uh platforms here to create an account
thank you so once you're logged in
you will see a number of resources
and we will be talking about some of
these resources today
so to gain free access to a lot of these
resources
all you need is the registration on the
portal so some of these resources are
going to be useful
in the program as well as in today's
session and after today's session you
can explore them a little bit more
so some of the things that we'll talk
about in these resources
are the terminology that we'll be using
today the logic of analysis building
different pipelines for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of data
what are some of the technical skills
that you will be needing
knowing how to visualize data and
explore that data using
r and python and then also you will see
how you can evaluate your understanding
of some of the topics that we will be
covering
by covering project applications of
bioinformatics
methods or quizzes for self-evaluation
now importantly we think that these
elements
really come complete a successful
journey for anyone coming from a very
introductory background so you might not
know
anything about bioinformatics before
joining this program
or you might already be an engineer or a
biologist
and the way that we view these uh
two parts of bioinformatics that biology
and the data
is that really they merge together as we
start speaking about some of the
applications of bioinformatics and the
only way to explore the applications of
bioinformatics
is to really focus on examples on
projects
and so what omixlogic portal does
is it offers a variety of specialization
tracks such as
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and
agriculture for anyone who's interested
in these topics to appreciate the role
data science and bioinformatics can help
in the research areas and
also in translational research how to
develop new applications for medical
purposes pharmaceutical agriculture
and others and so what the portal offers
is two separate tracks on biology on
data science using curriculum that was
evaluated by experts in these fields and
providing
resources that could be leveraged for an
effective program
now besides the program that we are
using
uh that we are discussing today we have
several other
tracks that you can benefit from so you
can look at
introduction to bioinformatics to kind
of get started and understand what it's
all about
you can learn specifically about genomic
data analysis and application to
infectious diseases oncology or
neuroscience
transcriptomic data analysis for
immunology studies
or for understanding of gene expression
in complex diseases
metagenomic analysis of data from the
microbiome where you sample
environmental samples and analyze their
composition
epigenomics the regulation of
non-genomic
variation in response to different
diseases or environmental changes as
well as
a training program on data science and
that program is specifically for those
that would like to get
practical hands-on skills for data
visualization data wrangling
statistical analysis as well as machine
learning
and artificial intelligence and so those
programs will be
offered and at the end of today's
session we will hear from dr mohit
mazumdar who will describe
what are some of the upcoming programs
that we have that we have on a rolling
basis
together these provide a complete road
map for data science in application to
biological
data or biomedical research and so you
can see
how finding data sets identifying
patterns through visualization
performing statistical analysis
and understanding the research methods
that you might read about or you might
be familiar
with as well as gaining biological
insights
into these data sets providing with
evidence-based or
data-driven hypotheses so that's really
the focus of this portal
and hopefully by now all of you
have had a chance to create an account
now
who benefits from such training we have
a few examples here as you can see this
could include
faculty researchers students we serve a
community of
participants from all around the world
including
india africa the us and europe
and so we are excited to kind of
continue and develop and build this
community that comes from
very diverse backgrounds but with a
common interest of application
of bioinformatics to a variety of
biomedical
and biological challenges so
to enhance this experience we also
welcome you to join
our group on linkedin we have a group of
professionals
that offer opportunities for internship
and jobs career building so if you're
interested
in the application of bioinformatics to
a variety of biomedical challenges and
you're looking for a job or you're
looking for an internship
we welcome you to join this community of
experts and students alike
so that you can learn about different
training programs
internships jobs and understand
how experts have gotten to where they
are today so
to join this uh linkedin group if mohit
you could share the link again
for the linkedin group and we also
have a group on facebook also for those
of you that use
facebook you can also join that
social media platform where we
do the same we post insightful resources
as well as opportunities for internships
mentorship job applications and
our participants that complete our
training are able to share
some of their projects as a result of
the research fellowship that they
conduct with
our company so besides the asynchronous
resources that we have covered today
the program that we're going to be
discussing today
the program is called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
will consist of several different
elements that work together to provide
a an experience an immersive experience
for anybody that would like to
learn about the applications of
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so this will include interactive
sessions like we're having today
it will point you to the right kind of
self-guided study materials that you can
use in between sessions to cover the
topics that we don't have enough time to
cover
as well as some practical assignments so
you'll actually be given
curated data sets you'll be able to
perform analysis
on our big data analysis platform that
we'll introduce you to
today as well as some coding exercises
so that you can explore
visualize and analyze this data for
biological interpretation
but for now let's take a little pause i
think that's enough about us and what we
do
and before we move on i wanted to ask
you
uh what is your background and where are
you coming
to this session from so the first
question that i have
what is your current level of education
um so i have a few answers here on the
screen
high school undergraduate degree like a
bachelor's
graduate degree like a master's degree
or postgraduate phd postdoc or faculty
so if you could put your answers in the
chat
um for anyone joining just now
we are speaking about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases but
i wanted to get to know the audience as
well so if you could
uh please put the answers in the chat uh
thank you kerry
okay so um one d would be
post graduate and then uh dickshire is
answering
undergraduate degree okay kevia is
saying
d d so a lot of postgraduate
uh undergraduate degree for uh
shayani all right great thank you vijay
isd
and ali is in graduate degree all right
so welcome
for all of you that are joining now so
great to have you here
and louis is saying indeed which is post
graduate
all right excellent all right great
thank you
and the other question is about
what kind of drove you right what is the
motivation for you joining this session
so again
this is number two so that's why i asked
one a
one b one c and then you know this is
number two two a two b
two c and two d uh so the first option
is to learn about bioinformatics maybe
you're coming with minimal background in
bioinformatics and you just want to
explore and understand a little bit more
about it
and number two to get familiar with
infectious diseases maybe you
have more experience in bioinformatics
and applications something else but you
would like to understand the
applications to infectious diseases
and for overview of bioinformatics and
biology
so infectious diseases includes bacteria
pathogens from parasites bacteria
fungi okay thank you ali
and then d to apply bioinformatics to a
research project so maybe you already
have a project in mind
maybe you have explored some data sets
and you would like to have
some mentor guidance and a better
understanding of how to properly apply
different types of bioinformatics
methods
to a project of your own potentially
you're already
a researcher trying to use those skills
all right great so i see a lot of you
are putting the d for
question number two and then also c an
overview of bioinformatics of
virology um thank you
okay so for those of you that are
interested in that last part of it to
understand
and to apply different types of
bioinformatics methods
to projects to data sets
from infectious diseases that's exactly
what we want to cover in today's session
so i'll give you a little bit of an
overview of uh bioinformatics
and application to different types of
pathogens
i will then introduce you to some of the
methods and data sets
that we will be using during this
program and i will
pause in between those different
sections so that you can ask any
questions that we can pause and discuss
in today's session
answer any of your questions and also
help you
envision how this program can help you
achieve some of these goals
so i will not be the only one speaking
both in today's session but also
throughout the program
we actually have a number of experienced
um a number of experienced
mentors that will be guiding and
assisting you throughout this program
and that includes dr harpreet kaur who
is a
omixlogic bioinformatics trainer and has
a phd in bioinformatics
particularly with a specialization in
genomics and oncology
as well as dr mohit mazumder who's also
here in the chat
and he is an expert in chemo informatics
as well as the application
or the relationship between sequence and
structure
and i'm sure that he will mention a
little bit about his background
uh towards the end of today's session
and so my name is elia brodsky i'm one
of the co-founders and the ceo of pine
biotech but i'm
involved in every aspect of what our
company does and i'm particularly
excited
about this program because i think it's
on everyone's mind
uh today even people that used to be
interested in oncology and neuroscience
are
now seeing the impact of infectious
diseases
on so many areas that we have been
interested in before
and i think that it's impossible to kind
of overlook the significance of what's
going on not only are we living in the
midst of a pandemic
we always hear in the news how there's
new development
and so because of these developments
it's important to understand
what we can do with the type of data
that is available
in such great quantities on the public
domain
and how we can actually contribute by
analyzing such data
to extract meaningful insights from
some of these data sets so what can they
tell us essentially
so this program called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
is going to focus on the relevant tools
methods data repositories and provide
some examples from curated data sets
where we can take sample data and
analyze it together during these
interactive sessions point you to some
project examples
on the learn omixlogic portal where you
can register for free and we'll be
utilizing some of those examples and
tutorials during the session
so that you can master some key elements
of analysis and visualization tools
and hopefully apply some of these
methods to a project of your own
so the objective of this program and
what we sincerely hope for everyone that
joins this program
is that you will start and learn about
something that is relevant to a research
project that you would like to develop
now this program is going to last for a
little bit
longer than just the previous program
that we completed
not so long ago that program was
exclusively focused on
the covet 19 variants there's some
overlap
between that program and this program
but we hope to
widen the perspective so that we can
look at
sequence variation evolutionary and
phylogenetic analysis like we've done
before
talk about functionality and protein
structure using several different
examples
and then also look at the transcriptomic
data analysis
so that we understand the host responses
and
potentially some of the immunology of
these infectious diseases
so let me for those of you that are
joining with
minimal background virology or
infectious diseases kind of start
from a little bit of a beginning
what are infectious diseases and how are
they different from
non-infectious diseases so infectious
diseases spread
by pathogen by pathogenic microorganisms
and those can include bacteria viruses
parasites and fungi
and you can see some of the examples
here on the left side so
flu hiv malaria and
some of these are very different types
of diseases so they affect different
tissues they affect different types of
cells
they have very different mechanisms of
infection
but we call them infectious diseases
because
there are several characteristics about
them that are unique so for example
transmission is an important factor the
way that they
replicate is going to be an important
factor and this is
going to be different from
non-infectious diseases that
are not caused by a pathogen so
typically they are considered to be
caused by
environmental factors nutrition
deficiencies
lifestyle choices and genetic
inheritance
and when we speak about uh this um
approach of studying infectious diseases
some of the things that we will be
focusing on
are replication or colonization
cell death so how does the pathogen
induce
the process of deterioration and death
as well as release of toxic and as a
result of that
how we can understand organ and tissue
damage so these are some of the
important factors
and surprisingly in the
maybe the past 10 or 20 years the
researchers have discovered that
even though we might not consider some
diseases to be
caused by pathogens some of the
conventional diseases that we think of
as non-infectious like cancer and
neurodegenerative diseases
might be associated with some of the
factors and one of the primary reasons
for that
is actually related to the way that our
body responds
to infectious diseases and so to talk a
little bit about the response you can
see here that
for example bacteria
and you can see that it is being
uh the response is is the
ability of the body to kind of uh uh
intercede
interceive uh in intercept
right i don't know how to properly say
that but to intervene
and so when we speak about infectious
diseases we also have to consider the
immune response to those infectious
diseases
where this rapid ability of the pathogen
to
replicate and colonize different tissues
is going to be important for
um okay
sorry one second looks like somebody
signed me out of this
okay so um
okay uh mohit and everyone else if
you're trying to use my account
please stop that i think i need it
for my presentation
okay ilya so actually the meeting with
uh there's another meeting with african
team
about machine learning so well maybe
tell them to
uh use your account or something else
because we do need this for now
sure okay this is my actually so yeah
okay okay so um
as a result we need to consider the
history
of interventions to help address the
spread of infectious
diseases and over the course of the
years
there have been several important
interventions
at the public health level that have
been very successful at reducing
the load from infectious diseases and
mortality so you can see here the rate
of infection
and the years and some of the important
interventions that have been
developed over the year like the
health departments and the public health
component then you can see the first
continuous municipal use of chlorine in
water in the united states
after pandemics especially these novel
interventions have been
applied in a much greater uh way
and then you can see how it helped
intervene with
transmission of important infections the
use of penicillin and the development of
antibiotics
as well as not so long ago if you think
about it
in the 1950s the intro the introduction
of effective vaccination
and so the types of challenges that we
are facing today
the reason why they are so inexp
unexpected is that we have
a fairly successful history of applying
our understanding of infectious disease
pathogens to prevention and to treatment
of infectious diseases and so even
though we
had this high level of confidence that
we understand the pathogens we
understand that the way they
interact with the host can lead to
disease and we know how to address and
prevent that problem
in the recent pandemic of course there
has been this
uh novel appreciation of a much
more in-depth uh characterization of
pathogens that cause these outbreaks
and the ability to translate our
understanding about these pathogens
to effective interventions and so here
you can see
how the recent pandemic has really
pushed the boundaries of what we know
about
intervention and treatment essentially
making covet 19
one of the leading causes of mortality
for pulmonary diseases um that have been
around
since you know for uh decades now
and so what that had led to is a greater
appreciation of the role that
bioinformatics
can play in our monitoring
characterization of infectious diseases
the way that they spread and how we can
treat them
effectively and so here you can see a
slide from the new
england journal of medicine where they
describe some of the applications of
genomic sequencing
to monitor these outbreaks of infectious
diseases now
one of the first infectious outbreaks
that has
um kind of been you know a breakthrough
moment
for genomic sequencing was the outbreak
of ebola virus in west africa in 2014
2016.
during that time for one of the first
times in history
genomic sequencing was applied in a
very on a large scale to monitor and
characterize
the ebola virus that was causing that
outbreak
but you can see some of the other
insights that could be gained from the
analysis of that data including insights
into virulence
protein expression to understand
potential proteins for direct design
proteins and immune response diagnostics
so that you can really understand
the type of a strain or even a specific
variant that is causing some
particular aspect of the clinical
manifestation of disease
insights into growth requirements so
that you can understand drug
susceptibility specific sequences for
strain detection and
outbreak investigation potentially there
could be zomotic transmission
or a rapid increase in transmission that
could be associated with the genomic
sequence so
really genomics has become a central
focus
for some of the infectious disease
monitoring and
translational research and that's why
using a lot of these applications
combined with the immunology of disease
is really so centered around data
management
data analysis and interpretation and so
when we speak about bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
some of the examples that we're going to
be looking at
is how can we compare different
sequences
from different similar viruses that are
nevertheless divergent over time and
causing different
clinical manifestations how can we
characterize
the molecular level of infectious
disease so that we can
compare the immune responses and
the uh type of responses that the human
body has
these pathogens um how can we identify
some of the important regions on
proteins that are
so critical for the infection itself
and how can we incorporate our
ability to manage and analyze data to
integrate this information together
and gain some reliable and interpretable
biological insights
into disease progression transmission
and treatment of specifically we will
probably focus on
bacterial viral and parasite
pathogens that cause some of the major
diseases
out there like covet 19 ebola virus
malaria tuberculosis and others
so before we continue i want to ask if
there are any questions
so again if you have any questions
please put them in the chat
i'm going to just give it one moment
here for anyone to write it out
so the objective of this session today
is to really make sure that the
topics of the upcoming program are clear
that you understand how you might
benefit from
joining this program and if you have any
questions either about the topics that
i've covered so far
or about any of these follow-up topics
please put those in the chat and i will
address them either now
or if i do have something prepared
already i'll mention that as well
okay so if you have any questions you
can continue
posting them in the chat i will pause in
a few more slides
and address them um as well okay and so
arjun is asking is there a certificate
of completion
how valuable could a certificate of
completion from this course be
in application to a master's program so
it's a great question i think that
anyone
that is trying to learn bioinformatics
one of the important part of
mastering bioinformatics i think is to
apply it to a
project of your own and likely you have
a thesis or a project as a part of your
masters
and that's one of the things that you
can really focus on during this
program i don't think that people today
when they hire uh you know people from
uh master degrees are looking so much at
the certificate
that you will get i think more so they
will be looking for
how knowledgeable you are to apply
what you have learned to tackle a
certain
problem and so we'll discuss several
case studies
in this program that will allow you to
see
what is the application of
bioinformatics from beginning to the end
of a research
project so how can you find a good data
set
how can you plan your analysis how can
you complete that analysis
and what are some of the important
critical questions research questions
that you can ask
about the data set that you have found
so that the
analysis that you present addresses
those questions
in a comprehensive way so you will get a
certificate of completion
but again i think the major outcome for
anyone in a master's level
will be to complete a project and
demonstrate your understanding of that
problem so arjun let me know if i
answered your question
and i'll be happy to expand on that
later on
and then lewis is asking uh can i
share the last two publications showed
in the slides
yes so we will share all of the links
for these publications
after the session is over if you could
reach out to us by email
so that we have your email address and
we will be happy to share that with you
okay and what does it take to complete a
project so
we'll talk a little bit about the
different stages of this program as i
mentioned it's going to include
training sessions and interactive
sessions like we're having now
it will include some practical
introduction to methods of analysis so
that you can take curated data sets
process them
and make sure that you're getting the
right results but also at the end we
will
leave some time for you to share with us
a proposal
on a project that you might find in the
public
domain so data sets from ncbi virus
from gis aid from other types of public
domain repositories like maybe malaria
gen so if you know of a data set you
will have
plenty of time to find and kind of read
the
literature about that data set propose a
project
that you describe just kind of based on
your understanding of the logic
this is the data set this is the
question or a comparison that i will ask
maybe you will perform some exploratory
data analysis and at the end you'll have
the opportunity to get some feedback on
the project and so you will be able to
address any issues that come up
so you can maybe enhance your project
make it more comprehensive make it more
interesting
maybe make it more focused on the topics
that are relevant
in that process
okay so bukari uh let me know if i
answer that question okay great
so because we are living in the time of
the pandemic right
we probably all have heard about source
goes to
the spike protein the genomic variation
of that spike protein
and i think that you know to get started
with
doing something meaningful in this
particular pandemic
the first thing that we need to
understand is how
relevant the different data that is
available
to a an impactful question right and so
i think that i would divide this
training into two parts
the first part which you might as well
do on your own
or you can do it together with our group
here is to learn about some of the
basics
the basics related to where did this
virus come from
how do we use bioinformatics to analyze
data
and test some of the hypotheses that
were proposed
what are some of the basic outcomes of
the analysis that we can use to
answer some of the questions and so i'm
going to go through a few examples and
this is the first one
and i'm using it as the first one
because this kind of an introductory
project
is something that you can try out after
you have completed your registration
on this portal so again i know that we
already did this in the beginning of
today's session
but if you have already logged in
let's go back to learn onyxlogic.com
and if you haven't please let register
on this portal so that you can follow
along
and see some of the examples that we
will be showing here in the next few
slides
okay so this is the link you will see
that
once you have logged in you will have a
profile
and you will have some personal
suggestions based on your progress
so as you start completing some of these
tutorials and mastering some of these
skills
it will start changing as you go through
the course work
and so right here you see that we have
the code 19
origin and pathogenesis of source code 2
so i'm going to share that link with you
as well
again if you haven't registered
registration here is free so just please
go ahead and
get started and one of the first things
and this i think will provide you with a
good
understanding of how this program will
work you will see
setting the background right setting the
stage for
what kind of questions should we be
asking
and how to translate those theoretical
questions
to practical data analysis process so
you'll see here
some introduction about the
coronaviruses
and what do they do what is the
important part of it
with transmission and then you will also
see what are some of the
important factors that you can learn
about here and
here you will see some of the objectives
some of the specific objectives that
will be covered
in this course in this project and so
similar to this project
in the course of this whole program we
will actually go through
quite a number of examples like this
so this one is on source code two
another one that we will go through is
malaria
where databases like malaria gen
and plasmodb offer us access to
a comprehensive collection of data from
different regions where malaria is
endemic
to identify some important factors on
drug resistance
on transmission as well as vaccine
efficacy
in application to different types of
data about different proteins different
populations
different years and so we'll be
exploring that data together as well as
a
part of this program as i mentioned one
of the first
examples where uh pandemics or epidemics
have been characterized at the genomic
level
almost in real time is the ebola virus
and so one of the projects that we will
be focused on
is that tracking of ebola virus
evolution
across that 2014-2016
epidemic in west africa and so as a
result of these
uh projects that we will dive into to
understand their background
to understand the specific questions
that could be asked about them
and understand some of the tools and
methodologies you will be able to
appreciate the role of omix data in
infectious disease research
and the application of bioinformatics to
be able to ask specific questions
about these data sets and so that will
give you an insight into viral genomics
in evolution
immune response biomarkers and the
relationship between microbiome
and infection now at the core of
all of these types of omics data we will
primarily focus
on next generation sequencing and one of
the
aspects of next generation sequencing is
that the technology itself
has evolved rapidly over the past
couple of decades essentially leading us
to where we are today where
there's just millions and millions of
sequences
and hundreds of thousands of data sets
that are
available for anyone to explore and
access
in the public domain that means that as
someone that comes
without the lab capabilities of
generating your own data
you can have access to data sets
produced at
top labs around the world in the best
academic centers where
people that have been trained for years
are sharing data that they generate
and all of us can just take that data
and analyze it and what that means is
that
it eliminates the concerns about the
quality of data
it eliminates the concerns about the
quantity of data so both quantity is
there
and quality is there and so i think that
makes this
an exciting opportunity and i think that
infectious diseases
is one of those areas where data is even
more prevalent and available
than than some of the other conditions
that you might be interested in
but to understand this data we have to
appreciate
the heterogeneity of this data as well
so essentially
as i mentioned the sequencing
technologies have evolved over the
years tremendously and now we have
short read sequences long read sequences
some of the technologies are
much easier to generate quality data
some of them have
some of these other issues and so we
will review the different types of
next-generation sequencing
data and data types before we jump into
that and so before i go into that
process of next generation sequencing
again i want to ask if you have any
questions
about what we have covered so far so
what we covered so far
is the overview of the omixlearn
omixlogic learn platform or portal where
you will have access to
data sets and tutorials that you can
learn from asynchronously
number two we started talking about
infectious diseases and how
research in infectious diseases can be
conducted as a part of this program
where you will be able to apply the
tools that you learn
to data sets that you find on your own
in the public domain
number three you will understand the
different types of data that are
available for the questions that you
might be asking
so you really have the freedom to choose
the type of a project or the type of an
application or a question that you might
have
about these data sets so again if you
have a question
uh please put that in the chat box and
i'll be
if i see the questions now i'll be
answering them now if not
then we will wait until the next pause
that we will have
to answer any questions that you might
have
okay so dr amitabh is asking
is the best pathway to complete the
introduction to bioinfo course before
enrolling
for this one um yes
if you are completely new to
bioinformatics
what i would recommend and let me
actually
show you a couple of things where you
can get started depending on kind of
where you see yourself going with this
process
there's a course on introduction to
bioinformatics that explains the
different applications of bioinformatics
about medicine to agriculture etc
there's also a course called bytes and
molecules so
bites and molecules is a course for
somebody who is you know just beginning
to kind of learn about some of these
topics
and you will see that here you will have
an introduction to
the human genome project you will see
the application of citizen science
how do these two kind of paradigms
converge together
to create a need for bioinformatics or
for
training in data science and then you
will see some of the basics what is
the genome what are nucleotides what are
amino acids
how do we go from sequence to function
right so some of those basic things
are going to be explained in this course
as well so either one
introduction to bioinformatics is kind
of probably the next step
and then bites and molecules is the kind
of first level where
you would begin as a newbie to this
topic
does that answer your question dr
amitabh
all right excellent so let's go on so
next generation sequence
to appreciate the opportunities provided
by
next generation sequencing we really
need to understand how next generation
sequencing works
and the way it works is that there's a
machine
that essentially takes the raw
biological material or rna
and dna and converts it into digital
data and this data consists of short
sequences
or reads as we call them that now
represent
a digital snapshot of what happens
at the subcellular level now when we
speak about infectious diseases that
means that we have
millions and millions of reeds about
that pathogen the virus the bacteria or
the parasite
and potentially how does it actually
look
in a real biological sample and it looks
like this right so this is the result of
mapping those short reads onto the
reference genome this is by the way
one of the first examples of mapping the
sequencing data from the wuhan outbreak
onto the reference genome of the
previously
known source one virus where you can see
how many many short reads provide us
with an
understanding of what is the consensus
sequence that we're ultimately going to
be looking at
and so to be able to analyze this data
we can perform what's called
sequence alignment and the sequence
alignment could be applied in two
different ways
one of them is alignment to a reference
when we have the raw reads and we want
to understand
the consensus or the variation from the
reference
or if we have a number of these
consensus sequences
how do they relate to each other or
multiple sequence alignment
where we can now explore the
relationship between them
based on variation that we see in the
sequences themselves
and so to seeing the application of
how these methods could be used let's go
on to the server
that omix server that t-bioinfo
where we will see how we can analyze
this data
and this is going to be for anyone even
if you don't have any background
in bioinformatics at all so i'm going to
go to
server.tbio.info if you
register on the learn omixlogic
portal you can use the same password
that you use there
maybe some of you already have a
password so just log in
and we'll take a look at one of the
sections to kind of see
what the process of analysis consists of
so once you're here we will see
how this portal has several different
topics that you could apply
analysis to and that includes analysis
of next generation
sequencing data mass spectroscopy
structural biology as well as methods
for data integration and modeling and so
what we want to do
is see how analysis of these sequences
can help reveal relationship between
these sequences
in application to a question that we
might have
about the source growth ii virus so i'm
going to go
under phylogenetic tree and i'll find
here several different demo
examples and one of those examples is
going to be this one
source code to origin right so it says i
have to click on the drop down
and then i have to click on demo source
code to origin
so as a as a demo as an example we don't
have to
upload the data the data is already here
what we need to do is we need to click
on several
of these buttons to see how this data
could be
analyzed so what is the process what is
the flow or the logic
behind such analysis so we have two
options as we mentioned we can upload
fast queue or fasta data in this case
you can see the input files
and those are bad coronavirus bad source
code 2
human source code 2 as well as some
pangolin data sets on source code 2.
right so the question here and this is
the question
asked in the tutorial that i shared
earlier is what is the relationship
between different sequences how could
they
be organized into what's called the
phylogenetic tree
so that we can analyze their
evolutionary
closeness how closely related they are
and when could they have diverged into
these separate
directions of adaptation and that could
help answer the question
what is this virus in humans and how
could it be related to some of these
proposed intermediate hosts
like bats or pangolins
so i'll click on the start then i'm
going to use multiple sequence alignment
to compare these
i will convert them to amino acid
sequences so i can understand the impact
of those mutations on the protein
sequences and then i will use
all phylogenetic methods that are listed
right here
to perform this phylogenetic analysis
now once i have
many different phylogenetic trees based
on different models mathematical models
that kind of represent the molecular
clock or the molecular evolution
that i observe at the sequence level i
can also analyze
the phylogenetic tree structures to
identify the best one
that is kind of convergent between these
different trees that i've
gotten as a result of many different
methods of analysis
so after i'm done with this pipeline i
will have here
several different outputs and i'm going
to take one of these
to see whether i can understand
something about
the relationship of these virus viral
genomes
so when i open this plot i'm going to
see here
different names and these names
represent
different fasta files that i have
uploaded
and so to appreciate the results i have
to annotate them
so essentially i have to look at how are
these
represented as a phylogenetic tree right
so each
branch here represents a
split from the origin and the nodes
represent a common potential ancestor
and so we can use this analysis to
understand how
evolutionary time or adaptation the
process of
evolution that we observe at the genomic
level has
gotten us the present day species that
we have collected the samples that we
have collected
so if we apply this technique to ebola
virus
we can ask the question about how the
different regions like
gabon liberia and great britain
relate to each other based on genomic
sequences
if we look at the source code 2 we can
also identify as i mentioned the
relationship between
the human source code 2 the bad
coronavirus
rad g13 or the bat sars-like coronavirus
as well as the pangolin and other types
of stars human viruses
so we can see the relationship
overall we can also find specific amino
acid
mutations in critical regions for
example this
spike glycoprotein mutation d
to g that was prevalent and became one
of the dominant mutations
potentially linked to increased
transmission rate
in the sars coronavirus so that is
the second part of what we will do in
this program and we'll talk about how do
we find
what are called mutations or snips
and so these snaps or mutations or
variants are important to be able to
analyze categorize and characterize
in terms of their uh impact on the
phenotype
and so once we perform alignment and we
can perform alignment
on nucleotide and amino acid level
what we're interested in are different
types of mutations
missense mutations nonsense mutations
and frame shift mutations and we want to
find
particularly those positions that could
indicate a change
in the protein structure so it could be
done using
multiple sequence alignment or it could
be used by
looking at all of the reads that we have
that represent potentially many
different viruses
present in a sample and identify in
identifying
variants of importance and that is
called variant calling
and so by variant calling we can
identify those snips that have a
potential
impact and then we can use different
methods
of characterization of protein function
to understand
how relevant they might be for a
specific
question of the impact of that mutation
on a structural component that we
have um identified as important to what
we're studying
and so here you can see several
different ways ways
that we can look at that and several
different ways that we can interpret
this kind of
information so what we'll do in the
program itself is we'll actually take
these
models of proteins that are on the host
side like for example here you can see
the host side h2 protein which is in
blue
but in reality this protein is actually
part of the complex
and this complex sits within the bo8
sodium dependent neutral amino acid
transporter
and then we'll also find the spike
protein which
also what we have from crystallography
studies
is just a component of that protein but
we'll look at how they
relate to each other by using ucsf
chimera and kind of mapping those 3d
structures onto each other
helping us understand how this virus
actually binds to the
host cell you can see the membrane right
here
and then try to make the interpretation
of a
mutation of a change in the structure
based on the impact that that would have
on protein
protein interaction just like we're
seeing here
so again this will give us some insight
into how
spike protein of source cove 2
which is a critical protein for both the
transmission
but also the vaccine prevention of that
transmission and prevention of disease
play a critical role the mutations right
those variants play a critical role in
all of those aspects
as we anticipate this pandemic to
continue and spread
and so in this program the
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
we will cover sequence variation
evolutionary relationships and how those
are measured
functional inference for sequence to
structure and function
as well as host response how can we
analyze the response of the host
transcriptomic data rna-seq data to find
patterns that can explain some of the
reactions that we see between mild maybe
severe disease
maybe symptomatic disease right maybe we
can look into the immunology of
different
immune cells etc okay so
any questions about the topics that we
will cover
in this program again if you have the
questions
please put those questions into the chat
box
and we will be answering those but for
the sake of time
i am going to now pass uh the session
over to dr mohit mizunder
so muhit mazumdar has been working with
us
to organize the schedules and the
logistics of many of the programs and
adapt them to the needs of different
levels of participants
so what he will do is explain a little
bit more about the different sessions
and the topics that will be covered and
how to register for this upcoming
program
over to you thank you idia
okay let me share your screen
hello everyone my name is mohit mazunda
and i have 12 years of experience
working and collaborating with pharma
and healthcare industry
to solve high priority scientific
questions related to biomedical data
science and
bioinformatics capacity building as
india mentioned
so some of the things that i would want
to mention before we move on to the
program overview is that the pace at
which firms have
like at this current time the pace at
which firms are
collecting and processing real-time data
is simply astonishing so
i would wanted to give you some examples
like tech farms in asia
have developed mobile apps to help
people check if they have taken the same
flight or train
to confirm uh the virus patients then
government officials are using data to
track individuals
that could use that uses the same data
and many apps are there which uses
infrared and ai powered
facial recognition to screen people at
uh you know
using this sort of data at the same time
google's deep mind is working to find
out about the structures of proteins
that are associated with covid19 so i
think a lot of things are happening with
data and for this
generation of researchers and students
there is an opportunity to discover
uh from big data and contribute
so in this specialization infectious
diseases
program um we will be
using curated data sets on infectious
diseases such as malaria
ebola enterovirus uh kovid19
as i said coronavirus uh host response
data
and we will be using public repositories
such as ncbi virus
so in this program we will understand
about the viral diversity
and we will learn about bio
bioinformatics analysis approaches to
study about the viral genome
and also we will gain hands-on
experience throughout the
sessions that will that i'll be showing
you next
so in these sessions how will we be
using
and analyzing curated data sets um for
which we have already prepared those
example
example projects for you to look at and
gain that experience
and then on top of it you will be guided
by experts
with bioinformatics experience and
knowledge about virology
so the first session uh is scheduled for
18th may so we are going to start the
session
on at the same time so the first session
will be about next generation sequencing
and viral genomes in host transcriptome
and then uh after that the next session
so we have 10 scheduled sessions
which will be happening over a period of
a month
so the first session is on 18th may the
second session on
is on 20th may and we will be sharing
you the detailed
uh schedule of the program via email as
well and it's also there
on our on our website so if you can if
you want you can look into that
uh after the session as well so the
second session as i was saying it would
be about multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic analysis
and this will be followed up by a
hands-on session
about preparing and running your own
pipeline so we will be doing multiple
sequence alignment of viral genomes and
then we will be
building phylogenetic trees and then
finding full genome sequences and
preparing those faster files
so all of that will be covered in this
third session on 25th
of may and then we have a q a and
discussion of pipeline results so all of
the
data that we will be generating and that
will the results that we'll be getting
getting we will be analyzing those and
understand the biological significance
or the
uh significance in the context of the
research so in that sense we will be
using and learning
about fasta and fast q files which data
bases to use for detection of uh viral
genomes by mapping on
those genomes to databases and then
interpretation
of phylogenetic phylogenetic
interpretation where we are
talking about evolutionary relationships
between
genomes and all of that so
after that uh the next session is about
is about the infection to pandemic so
the viral adaptation here we will be
talking about
hosts and origins so this will be on to
a 1st
june 2021 and
transmission and then cell entry and
tissue
tropism uh after that on
uh third june we have this session which
is
about the symptoms severity so here we
will be talking about the disease
progression
and the outcomes of that how the virus
is replicating and what is the process
of immune invasion and how we can
see that through the data
followed by that we have a hands-on
session again
on 8th june so on 8th june we will be
working on the origin
of human infection with taking examples
and this will be a comparative study
because we will be looking at
different viruses like mers source and
surge 2 and comparing their
um their origin uh by looking at
doing the sequence analysis so this will
be
on 8th june as i said and this will be
followed by the next session which will
be on 10th june
so which is about the variance so the
rate of mutation
and how to identify variance what are
the point mutation substitutions
insertions
and about the mutations like what are
the synonymous mutations
what are the non-synonymous mutations
that you are hearing about
so much and also like uh the current
scenario with covet 19 and the variant
analysis
uh that is also a part of this program
so uh that will be uh done on 10th
and after that we have the session on
annotation and significance of the
analysis as i was keep on
saying that relating the uh results that
we get from big data and then
you know connecting it to the biology or
to the
analysis results so we'll be looking at
the location on
genome and protein function so that
would be on 15th
june and the same week the next session
will be about host pathogen interaction
where we will be discussing about the
protein protein interaction that elia
discussed
and the host response and the immune
response so
what is happening with the adaptive and
innate immunity and then
about that considering the
bioinformatics
and the holistic understanding of the
system biology considering all what we
have
learned how this can be factored in for
you know
vaccine design how these all plays a
role with a data driven decision
to go for a very specialized sort of
vaccine design that could
you know address the problem of the
variants that could address
the problems of uh the changing epitopes
and all of that so that would be on 17th
june uh
so that would be about the schedule and
i'll pause here
for a second and i'll look at if you
have any questions
about these
so if there are no questions here
okay
okay so okay again i just wanted to
mention that the recording of this will
be made available on our youtube channel
and we'll send a follow-up email to
those of you that asked any questions so
some of you asked
for some of the reference publications
or
how to register so that will be shared
by email as a follower
yeah okay thank you india and then as i
was saying that once we
have learned about this the next
opportunity as
we've been discussing is to be able to
come up with a research proposal or to
be able to
uh work on a project so this
independent project our research
proposal is the time when we develop
within that
period of one month by talking to you by
uh one-on-one meetings or in a group
meeting and discuss
that how we can leverage the
online publicly available data sets
and the tools that we have available
here the cloud infrastructure
and to come up with you know research
proposals that could be
uh new research so
that would be about the program so this
program will con
will consist of several resources and
some of the resources
as elia have already shown so one of the
places that you should go
to is the learn platform
so we have in this entire omics logic
program have several
has several components so those
components include the training material
data analysis tools curated project
examples
and interactive sessions such as this so
i hope that does that
is clear to everyone that we will be
using multiple resources to come up and
learn about this innovative and new
field of
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so i think if you have not yet created a
login on the learn platform
so please do that so it's it's a free uh
free login that you can create
and use some of the free resources that
are there and then
you can also choose to join the
subscriptions that i'll be showing you
the next
next so this program will be utilized
you will also utilize the t-band for
platform
where we will be running the uh running
the analysis big data analysis
and there are several sections as you
have already seen many of you have
uh maybe have seen the demonstration use
the demonstration passwords
and email by your own email
so yeah obviously you can do that as
well so
uh also after that we will be utilizing
the coding platform
as discussed uh and we'll be utilizing
some of the
analysis downstream analysis that are
required for us to learn from this data
so this would include the visualization
and getting
uh uh classification done
for this uh for different types of texas
so out of this uh entire experience you
will be able to understand from the
scientific literature
and describe that describes the omics
data so you'll be able to
uh perform next generation sequencing
analysis
within uh accuracy and with
reproducibility
and you'll be able to do uh exploratory
data analysis and generate an hypothesis
so that is something that we discussed
for the projects
and then do statistical analysis and
do some of the machine learning analysis
if required for
you to go into the omics data and find
out those patterns
and then we do the annotation uh using
the
databases that are available online and
then we find out the
relationships and write about a story
and write about what we have found in
our entire
research project or research
program so that is something that it
will encompass
and other than that uh i would like to
now take you to the registration page
which is uh fairly simple so uh
just a second so let me share you with
the
registration link and or elia if you can
share the registration link
actually i'm not sure what the
registration link that you'll be using
so
please share
just a second
so we have already emailed the
registration
details so in case if you have any
questions
feel free to put them in the chat and
we'll be able to answer that
meanwhile let me share my screen and
show you the
registration process
so this is the portal
infectiousdiseases.omicslogic.com
so let me put it in the chat box
and uh to answer the question about
shayani about the course fee so i'll
just
be doing showing you that so here you
can click on get started
and then you can here you can choose
from three different levels
so beginners intermediate and advanced
so here you will be able to get
uh the information about different
levels so the beginner level
uh has all the components that we have
discussed today including all the
licenses that are there and all the
platform access and all the projects
and the difference between intermediate
and beginners is that you will get
an additional mentor support uh in the
intermediate package
and in the advanced one if you're
working on your own data if you're
working in a lab that is generating data
and you would want to
analyze that which is not available on
public repositories
then you can choose for the advanced
license and uh
collaborate with us to work on your
research project
so anyways uh to tell you more about the
pricing the cost of this beginner's
license one month uh hands-on program
is 205 and uh
we have a 30 discount code available
on top of it so you can select here and
you can
write the 30 discount code and uh
with that that would be the uh that
would be the
price or the cost of this program
provided that you get the early bird
scholarship
so these are three different methods
that you can
pay pay through and you can also pay via
bank transfer or upi if you are
if you don't have a card or if you want
that help and assistance
for joining the program so please let me
know if you have any questions or any
clarifications that are required for you
to understand about this